good morning believe nation today's
message is learn how to sell yourself
over to you Patrick bid David Levy gold
selling is something you'll always do
the rest of your life most people don't
like selling some people like to kind of
make it nice and sound use a better word
and say communication or just its sales
by the way those that just turn off the
video and don't want to watch about what
selling has to do hey you want to marry
that girl you love
you know which one I'm talking about you
need to sell her and her parents and her
best friends that's all selling you want
to get that promotion purely selling
baby and those who get that promotion
sell better than you do that's why it is
they don't sell a car their job could be
human resource or something but they
learn how to sell themselves as that
position more than you maybe you ought
to learn how to do it'll benefit you
make you a lot of money so what do you
think I think Patrick is right selling
itself or people that use the word
selling they immediately think of like a
used car salesman and has this huge kind
of like negative connotation a really
great book that I read on this Daniel
pink to sell is to be human or selling
his human and he said like selling you
have to sell if you're a parent you have
to sell your kids on eating broccoli you
know if you're a dentist and you think
you're above you know the used-car
salesman get the sell your patient into
getting that root canal
I think selling is such an overlooked
kind of asset in all of society whether
you're an entrepreneur whether you're a
parent boyfriend girl doesn't matter but
it's one of those things that everyone
that does it really really well and it's
about them communicating their idea
expressing it in a way that persuades
you know the people that they're trying
to persuade right it's not just about
kind of conning people into you know get
into this you know use car type of thing
a lot of times its ideas that we believe
in ideas that you know we really think
you know should have a deeper impact
with people doing videos like this that
can help people see different parts of
perspective and business and in life
I think selling is such an overlooked
thing but it's also such a crucial step
if you want to be successful in selling
your idea I think it's a great power and
what's the Spider Man with great power
comes great responsibility I know I have
the ability to convince people to do
things just out of sheer passion in
conviction and often when you're in a
debate you know somebody wants something
somebody want something else the person
has more passion and the person is more
certain of course or has more confidence
often wins even if the other person was
cemented in their position if you come
at me with a lot of passion and
confidence that you're right
I will now start to doubt myself so the
person has a lot of certainty usually
wins those kind of negotiations it's a
really powerful important skill to learn
where I then add to it as I always try
to make sure that it's in their best
interest to and not just I think that's
where like the sleaziness can come off
like I'm just trying to sell this guy I
can convince him to buy anything and
it's going to be great for me but that's
really piece of junk that I'm selling
right so I'm always focused on like the
long term like my brand and impact and I
want that person to win too and I'm
selling them on a future that I believe
in for themselves where I often have to
push people past their comfort zones to
do something they're afraid of that they
never thought they could do it's that's
what believe is all about for me too and
I'm selling them on a brighter future
but it's in their best interest to like
yeah it may help me but it's good for
you too I think the people who do that
best are the biggest change leaders and
having a huge impact the people use it
for you know nefarious purposes just to
benefit themselves they don't last very
long and get a really bad reputation and
so I think that may be kind of a
dividing line where sales itself is a
super important skill to learn and just
to add on there's a lot of entrepreneurs
out there or at least I've seen you know
whether I've spoken with them and at
different conferences or I just met them
in my own journey where they get into
this kind of cycle where they want to
just give everything right and this is
obviously assuming that it's something
of value that they're able to kind of
educate or inspire others to do
something or they have something that
actually is a value to them but they end
up giving so much right and then they
realize oh my god I can't you know so I
can't possibly support my family or I
can't possibly have my business
especially in those early stages and I
think selling is the way it's like the
one skill that especially if you're
starting out is going to be able to help
you kind of get that momentum get that
ball rolling especially if you have
something of value to the market and you
just have to be able to not just make
noise to make noise but to make noise in
your own benefit but obviously like you
said benefit the other person as well so
the question of the day today is on a
scale to 1 to 10 how good are you at
selling your own ideas to others we're
getting self-reflective they're 1 to 10
put it down the comments below and we're
going to join a discussion thank you
guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe or
whatever your one word is and we'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of an spresso oh wait this spray so
give me go